Yeah. So, um, I know that you, you actually watched our video.
You were also there during the live while we were kind of talking about the
topic, correct.
Was, yeah. Uh, and for you,
when you were there during the live,
basically were talking to a bunch of ladies who said that,
like they wanted to raise a kid by themselves and, and they were excited.
And I know, I know that yourself you're single mom,
so I kind of wanted to get your perspective on it. Uh,
just cause I felt like it's always kind of good to hear from different folks.
And so what did you think about that whole discussion?
People wanted to raise kids by themselves, their attitude in regards to like,
what did you think when you were little?
Well,
at first I thought we need to put some more respect on our names because it's
not easy at all. I don't know.
There wasn't a single mom there that said that they would do that.
It was only people that didn't have any kids. Right, right.
What, what it is that they're missing. Cause I hear like, oh,
if you got a village or you know, all this, oh, I was gonna.
Touch on that. Yes. That should earth the outta me. <laugh> okay. First of all,
when we think about that whole, what that means it's, it's like it's,
it's a different community. It's not like Western community. When,
when you say we have a village it's completely different, right? Mm-hmm,
<affirmative>,
they're intertwined and they're helping each other in a way that we,
north Americans don't do that.
We're completely separated by our lives and our jobs and our homes and our,
where we live, et cetera.
So people might make the most promises to you when you got a little sucker in
your stomach. But trust me, those 3:00 AM, wake up calls and,
and the postpartum depression and the colleague babies that cry your village is
not gonna be there. They're gonna be sleeping. Cuz they have to go to work.
You might wanna be a single parent.
Right. But are you gonna be single forever?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> cause it's just like,
you think you're just gonna decide to date and just bring somebody into your
house and just like, okay, this is my child. Love them.
That's not how it will works. If there's complications and dynamics,
it's not the same kind of love as if you were with the father. Well,
but when I wanted to be in a relationship,
<laugh> the biggest issue is trying to bring everyone together because that
person's not gonna parent or an a parent the way you want to,
your kid's not gonna want this random man. That all of a sudden you're in love.
Okay. That ain't my daddy either the right. So <laugh>
that's real. But am I.
Wrong? No, you're not. How about I tell you in just to be like,
just to feel like, yo, I got my dad's back.
I'm gonna reject him outright because I'm loyal to my dad.
No one's gonna replace him.
So sometimes there's even a resentment that builds there where it like puts a
strain on the person trying to come in. Right.
Exactly. And then he's gonna be like, listen,
I ain't trying to freaking fight my whole life with this little. I love you.
Not him. Right, right. Or her mm-hmm <affirmative> so it's this thing.
And then on top of that,
you're dealing with responsibilities that that person you're bringing in,
they don't have to, they don't have those same responsibilities.
It's not their kid. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so you wanna be and, and another, oh,
I can go on forever. So you wanna be working.
You wanna be a partner to this new partner.
You wanna be a parent that's a fair and emotionally fulfilling.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> you wanna be able to give back to yourself and have your
own time. It's impossible to do that. Everything equally,
even if you had the father there.
So if you're by yourself to think that you're gonna be able to give yourself and
your child every, and the other thing.
That people consider is like, yeah, I make a lot of money. So it'll be like,
listen, oftentimes the issue isn't even the money's aspect.
Sometimes it's just time.
That's what it is. Most of the time,
I don't really hear kids too much being like, you didn't buy me Teddy rocks bin.
And all my everything's <laugh> everything is always eighties. But yeah,
you don't hear that. It's like, you weren't there. I didn't,
you didn't come to my prom or whatever I could.
It's always the more fulfilling things that I think that kids have resentment
for, you know, mm-hmm, <affirmative> that hear about the most,
sometimes it's money, but most of the time not,
and you might be able to have all the money in the world, but guess what?
You're at work, making that money.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> with your kid. Right.
And you're preaching. Yeah. I speaking on the heart, you know? Yeah.
And then on top of that,
you open up your child and they're more susceptible to vulnerabilities because
yeah, that's a babysitter, but criminal record child don't mean. Okay.
Somebody's crazy. And they've never been arrested before.
What does that mean? A lot of times in court,
when you hear about kids getting taken advantage of it's about a third party
that was brought into the home under the idea that the mother trusted them,
whether it was a partner or a babysitter they hired or anything mm-hmm
<affirmative> and your child is vulnerable to complete strangers,
regardless of how much you trust them. <affirmative> you know, so,
and you're going to have to do that if you're gonna be working and you're a
single parent, so yeah. It's just crazy to me. It's like,
why take away? Like I just don't understand. What's better than one.
Parent's love two parents love. Right.
So I don't get why you would actively, sometimes happens.
I had no business having a baby with the guy I chose,
but why would you actively make that decision? Yeah.
Um, what are some other struggles that you had for you.
Individually? Okay. Well,
I was lonely as Hale because when I had a baby and none of my friends had babies
and they weren't, or they had babies and they had a partner,
they had a lot more freedom than I did. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so,
and wanna come over to your house so that you be like, one second,
I gotta pull my TDL or one second, I gotta go to, you know,
they wanna be around you when you're able to get there.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> so you spend a lot of time alone with your child and it's a
lot because your child's not, you might love your child,
but they're not gonna give you that adult one-on-one that you need that what you
need from other members of society. They're just like paw patrol. Mm.
You know what I mean? So you're missing out on that. Then I chose,
I had to earn money. I was on Ontario works at first, but I was like, this.
So when I decided to go to school, I didn't sleep at all. Mm-hmm <affirmative>.
So unless these ladies are completely like they're done with their career
choice, then it's a horrible decision to be single parent and, uh,
try to get your career.
And you, I lost my earning potential because I'm at home with my kid.
And even though my job is still available to me, I, they don't,
I don't get to have a repertoire with people that come in, things change.
And I don't know what they are. People forget about you.
Your Bo the connection you have with your boss is not as strong as it was before
you left.
Because when you're gone for two years is a long time to not to be at a company.
Yeah. And that's only if everything runs smoothly with your child,
because some children have disabilities that they're born with and other issues.
So you lose your earning potential.
Regardless if you have your job or not lonely. Hell, um, they're expensive.
They're draining. Mm-hmm <affirmative> they require a lot. When I say a,
when I, when I say a lot.
Talk to 'em, listen, you got firsthand experience.
So you could give tangible experience. So go ahead, bro.
They don't sleep, sleep. I was very confusing. They, they,
they say they sleep for three hours every hour.
But if you are spending one hour breastfeeding,
one hour burping and trying to get them to bed,
then they're really only sleeping for an hour mm-hmm <affirmative>.
And that's time for you to wake up a grown as adult. And you can't say, babe,
can you just take this? Can you just let me put, gimme a bottle?
And you do with that you're by yourself. Then you don't know. My daughter had,
she had issues like she was colicky. And she was, um,
I had to take her to the hospital a couple of times for her own personal medical
issues. And, um, I did that by myself, you know,
and I was exhausted. And then when I decided to go to school,
so basically you lose your sleep. So if you like to sleep, it's over and then,
and you get resent them with them too,
because I presented my daughter's father because I'm like, yo, this guy's free.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> he do whatever he wants. Mm-hmm <affirmative> I, yeah,
I didn't bother. I felt like it was my choice.
You can't draw blood from a stone so I can waste all my time trying to take him
to court. I know he ain't doing mm-hmm <affirmative> right.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> so of course,
a bunch of resentment bills up and then it will naturally,
you will take it out on your child. I'm telling you right now,
you won't realize it, but you're gonna snap on them.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> they're gonna get on your nerves and it will be you cuz and
you won't have that release to be like, no, let,
let me just chill for the day because I don't wanna take it on you.
You have to be there for them.
When you, when you talk to other single parents,
like do they echo a lot of the same sentiments and issues that you mentioned?
Oh yeah. Even worse. Yeah, absolutely. They're drained. They're tired.
I've had my friends call me sometimes and be like, listen, I hate this little.
Like I, I, I don't know. I feel terrible, but like it's constant.
It's incessant. Um, they're just cry uncontrollably.
They hate eat the way their body looks. Their hormo,
their hormones are all messed up.
Cuz you have to think your body goes through the biggest changes ever gonna go
through its entire life. Right.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> mm-hmm <affirmative> and your,
your kids inside of you basically sucking life outta you for nine months.
<laugh> right? Yeah. So when you have a baby you're you are so tired.
You're supposed to have that support system there so that you can, you know,
bounce back. Right.
But when you don't get that and you have all this other financial worries, um,
just loneliness, whatever the, you undoubtedly,
it affects you mentally to the point where I've had parents can't get out of
bed. Right. Um.
Let me ask you, so you, um, and you don't mind your kids, how old at this point?
17. Yeah. She's 17.
And have there been moments even now as she's grown older that have been maybe
a bit awkward or,
or difficult due to you being a single mom or due to like just the situation
with the father and stuff like that?
Yeah. Well, for me, like, uh, for my daughter and her father, I don't,
even though I have my issues with him,
they're not her business because like I chose him, so I don't talk about him.
And I don't like, if they wanna see each other, that's fine.
They have FaceTime, they talk whatever. Right.
Mm-hmm but I do know parents that are like, he ain't.
Why do you wanna see him for, he ain't even give, oh, he impeded,
you know what I mean?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and so that can be awkward when you see kids,
like just sitting there, watching their mom, just bad mouth, the dad and,
or just, you know, or, or even say like, I do everything for you and da, da, da,
and you want more and you know what I mean? It's like, well,
if you chose the dad, he, you could have had more to give.
And now you're mad at the kid because they want more from you that can't give
mm-hmm <affirmative> cause you're only one person. Right. Right.
And what I've noticed is that when you make these decisions and you figure out
that you decided it was a bad idea, your children make those decisions too.
My mom was a single mother and I'm a single mother and I'm trying to stop it
right now from my daughter being a single mother. But it goes down the line.
Your decisions are generational.
So you really need to think about what it is that you're doing at that time.
Okay. I, I really, I find that interesting. So you said,
what is it about the way that your mom raised you,
that you think primed you more likely to be in this scenario, in your.
Opinion? Um, two things. One, I,
I was observant and I noticed what was going on at whatever time. And two,
she didn't talk to, to me about, about it. Right? So if my mom had been like,
listen, girl, I, I love you, but this was hard.
And I suggest that you don't ever, we didn't have that discussion. So for me,
I just, you just wanna emulate your mom or if things happen to you,
like it happened to your mother, you feel like no big deal. My mom did it.
Right. Mm-hmm <affirmative> so it's super important for me,
cuz a lot of these kids or these, these women that were talking in your chat,
they said that their moms are single moms and their moms did a great job,
but did they talk to their moms about the nuances and what was like really going
on,
maybe behind the scenes and how they felt at that time and the depression she
might have gone through because we don't always share everything cuz we feel
like we're gonna her, our kids. Right.
So you're not getting the full scoop when you say, oh my mom was single mom.
I could do it. Yeah. You don't know how many nights she cried by herself.
How stressed out she was, maybe she went hungry sometimes so that you could eat,
but you didn't even notice that. Hmm. You know what I mean?
Or depression she might have had cuz she feels like I can't be the woman that I
thought I could be because I have, I, I made this, you know what I, I mean,
I mean you do.
Represent me. I I'll I'll confess this to you,
but like that's always one of those things where I'm like,
I feel like as a parent,
you inherently have to sacrifice a lot of your own wellbeing in order to make
sure that your kid is good.
But sometimes it's almost to a degree that's unfair when you're a single parent.
I think all parents have to sacrifice, but for single parents even more so,
you know your own and a lot of people,
I think don't understand what that burden looks like and what they're signing up
for when they're making the choice so casually. So it, me to me,
it's not just like, don't necessarily do it. It means it's like,
if you're gonna do it, understand what you're getting into.
And most people don't.
Being casual. Exactly. That's what it is. It's just like you,
you're not really understanding. And for, and for it to be that casual,
that shows that you are not going to be that good of a parent that you think you
are or else it wouldn't be a casual decision. Mm-hmm <affirmative> like,
it's sorry to make you. You feel bad. But if you actually think about it,
I'm gonna love the I a kid to and give them everything.
Why would you not wanna multiply that.
Too? Yeah. Yeah. I completely get that just.
Okay. Yeah. It just sense. And I did have resentment my daughter. Absolutely.
And I don't know if it showed, um, I'm sure I had my days where I'm just like,
I wanted my alone time. Like listen,
when she's made her first bowl cereal by herself, I was so happy.
You know, you had to,
that was like my be my favorite day was the first time she could pee by herself.
You know? It's just like everything,
every thing is on you. <laugh> right. You know? Right, right.
It's a whole human that doesn't know how to do. Fathers are awesome, man,
if you can pick the right father, you gotta, you gotta take some accountability.
You can't pick guys that don't wanna do and don't care about the fact that
you're having a baby. And then when you make a decision to be with him,
it turns to. Now I hate every man and I'm gonna, you know, mm-hmm,
<affirmative> take your time.
But I would even to this day as a 39 year old woman,
if I could have a father that was had a together, mm-hmm <affirmative> right.
That would love me. Gimme that, love that only a father can give.
I would take it any day.
All right. Well listen, I think we had a really good back and forth about this.
I appreciate it. Yeah. And I'm glad you came on as a correspondent.
Anytime I have, uh, anything you wanna chime in on?
Just hang me up and we can see if we can set that up. Yeah.
So
mommy.